the reason we're seeing the dem
narrative go into overdrive is because
the democrats do not have an october
surprise and the republicans do
so that they have to just contrive the
october surprises so they'll say
trump trump called the troops losers or
something you say well do you have any
evidence of that they'll say no
okay or they'll say trump has a secret
bank account and say well do you have
any evidence of that say yes tax records
so then it's not secret uh rudy giuliani
as well rudy giuliani this is my
favorite one
this is my favorite one they're cooking
this up because
republicans have the october surprise
republicans have the receipts
and specifically rudy giuliani actually
has the receipts he's been
breaking day by day by day this hunter
biden
slash joe biden scandal so they're going
after rudy here's the big story you
probably saw this on twitter
rudy giuliani was filmed with his hands
down his pants in a hotel room with a 15
year old girl
that's the story okay that's the
headline that you're seeing
except that didn't happen rudy giuliani
was doing an interview for the new borat
movie
and obviously the way borat now works is
bora just tries to
to get a bunch of republican figures to
humiliate themselves
so they go they shoot in this hotel room
and
there wasn't a 15 year old girl there
was a 24 year old girl there
and they're in the room and then there's
this compromising photo of rudy giuliani
with his hand being tucked into his belt
underneath his belt rather so what's
happening here is rudy
in the midst of some obscene act you
know like the act that jeffrey toobin
just committed that the whole left wing
is trying to say we should forgive
and forget about and bring him back onto
tv
opinion articles about this going around
all yesterday no it's not what's
happening at all
even according to the editorial director
of mother jones maybe the most
far left wing outlet out there no love
lost between mother jones and rudy
giuliani
this guy tweets out i have now seen the
scene with rudy giuliani and though it
is creepy
for other reasons it is being described
on twitter in a false way
he does not have his hand down his pants
in a sexual way he is tucking his shirt
back in
after she untucks it removing his mic i
knew this the minute i saw the story
i said this something about this story
doesn't smell right to me
there's no video no one can actually see
the scene they're trying to push this
borat movie both
to make money on the movie and they're
releasing it around this time so that it
can
have an effect on the election i said
okay we're not getting the video
the movie was screened months ago and
nobody brought this up then
and if if you've ever done an interview
you know
that when you take your microphone off
no matter where the mic pack is it could
be in your pocket it could be
down your pants it could be in your on
the back of your belt but no matter
where you put it if the mic is being run
up
your shirt your shirt will come undone
you've got to tuck your shirt back in
that happens to everybody well why was
he in the hotel room why don't i assume
that the borax crew
had him filming in the hotel room why
was borat in the hotel room because he
busted in after and then had the
punchline
apparently at the scene which is no no
she's 15 she's too old for you
which is kind of funny writing but the
whole setup is is pretty ugly because
it's not legitimate we now have evidence
that hunter biden had
underage pornography on his laptop we
know that jeffrey toobin
just uh had a lot of fun with himself on
a work call
both of those being pushed out of the
news right both of these left-wing
scandals one in the media won
in the political realm because rudy
giuliani tucked in his microphone it's
just a little too
convenient and it's just bs
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you